Quand je raconte que j'ai fait
des études de géologie,
la première chose qu'on me demande c'est :
qu'est-ce qui ne tourne pas rond chez toi ?
Et la deuxième c'est : est-ce que les géologues
lèchent vraiment des cailloux ?
Non seulement oui, mais je vais
vous expliquer pourquoi.
(musique romantique au piano)
En général, quand un géologue tombe sur
un caillou dans la nature,
la première chose qu'il a envie de faire,
c'est de lui donner un nom.
Il peut l'appeler Jean-Michel ou Kevin, ou
bien argile, calcite ou...
J'en n'ai pas d'autre.
Pour l'identifier, le lécher, ça peut l'aider.
Je me souviens de mes premiers cours de géologie,
quand les profs nous demandaient
de lécher des cailloux
on pensait à une blague ou un bizutage,
on ne comprenait pas très bien.
Mais non, apparemment, ça fait partie
intégrante du process,
même si on n'avait pas forcément envie
d'arriver à ce degré d'intimité avec la planète Terre.
La première bonne raison de lécher un caillou,
c'est parce que quand on le mouille,
on révèle certaines structures,
on voit mieux les minéraux
et parfois, on voit même des fossiles
qu'on verrait pas d'habitude.
On peut aussi le passer sous l'eau, mais c'est
moins fun et ça gaspille une ressource naturelle
et on sait à quel point les géologues tiennent
compte de l'environnement.
La deuxième bonne raison, c'est parce que
lécher un caillou, ça peut aider à l'identifier
parce qu'il peut avoir du goût.
L'exemple le plus beau qu'on prend à chaque
fois, c'est la halite.
On l'appelle aussi sel gemme ou sel de terre.
Petite parenthèse, la halite se forme en
général quand une mer ou un océan s'évapore.
Ils laissent derrière eux des dépôts qui
se fossilisent, sont enfouis, tout ça tout ça.
On trouve des gisements de halite
un peu partout en France,
et en plus quand des sources resurgissent
à travers ces couches,
ça peut donner des sources d'eau salée.
C'est assez amusant.
Un des éléments clé pour reconnaître la
halite, c'est son goût salé.
Petite démonstration.
Ca n'a pas du tout un goût salé parce que
c'est de la calcite, je n'ai pas de halite.
C'est drôle parce que la calcite, la halite
et le gypse se ressemblent beaucoup.
Et c'est justement en les léchant qu'on peut
les discriminer.
J'ai toujours pas de halite mais j'ai été
ramasser du sel au bord d'un marais salant.
C'est pareil, c'est une roche qui se forme
par évaporation, ce qu'on appelle une évaporite.
Et là, pour le coup, c'est salé sa race.
Ça irait très bien sur des frites.
Par contre, c'est pas forcément parce que
c'est salé que c'est de la halite.
D'autres minéraux ont un goût salé.
Par exemple, la sylvite qui paraît-il, a
en plus un arrière-goût amer un peu dégueu.
Mais c'est quand-même vachement pratique :
si votre roche a un goût salé, ça permet
de limiter le champ de recherche de plusieurs
milliers de minéraux, on en a 5000 connus
à ce jour, à deux douzaines,
donc c'est plutôt pas mal.
Y'a d'autres minéraux qui ont un goût amer,
par exemple, comme l'epsomite.
Elle a la même composition chimique
que le sulfate de magnésium
qu'on peut trouver en magasin spécialisé.
Après on a la pyrite, du sulfure de fer.
Du coup, elle a un goût et une odeur d’œuf
pourri, c'est toujours charmant.
Et si votre échantillon a un petit goût
de paradis,
c'est peut-être aussi
qu'un animal sauvage s'est oublié dessus.
C'est pas plus mal,
ça renforce votre système immunitaire.
C'est un peu l'Actimel du géologue.
Et si jamais votre échantillon
a un goût de chocolat,
c'est que c'est pas du tout un caillou.
La troisième bonne raison de lécher un caillou,
c'est pour estimer grossièrement sa porosité.
Si ça colle à la langue, c'est poreux.
C'est pratique pour différencier les fossiles du reste.
En général, les fossiles sont très poreux.
Ceux qui ont un squelette, notamment.
C'est composé d'alvéoles
qui sont remplies de vide (d'air*).
Du coup, ça boit l'eau.
C'est vachement pratique quand vous êtes
sur le terrain pour discriminer des fossiles
d'autre chose.
Vous prenez un caillou qui a l'air de rien,
vous le collez sur votre langue,
et si ça happe votre langue, c'est peut-être un fossile.
Voilà.
Certains minéraux vont aussi coller à la
langue, comme certaines argiles.
La kaolinite, à partir de laquelle
est faite la porcelaine,
et la montmorillonite,
que je vous raconterai un peu plus tard.
Ces argiles absorbent l'eau.
C'est de très bonnes éponges.
Ca vient de leur structure en feuillets, entre
lesquels circulent des molécules, dont l'eau.
Du coup, ça va rester collé à votre langue,
un peu comme une hostie.
Je vous parlais de la montmorillonite, qu'on
appelle aussi terre de Sommières.
C'est un des constituants des argiles gonflantes.
C'est ce qui vous donne
ces paysages à la "Roi Lion" en été.
C'est un peu la bête noire des gens qui construisent
des maisons parce que comme une bonne éponge,
elles vont gonfler quand il y a de l'eau,
et se rétracter le reste du temps.
Du coup, si vous avez une maison dessus,
elle va se fissurer
et ça deviendra une maison à la Picasso.
Pour la petite histoire,
pause boisson
AH
Pour la petite histoire, on a même trouvé
de la montmorillonite sur Mars.
Si jamais vous y allez, vous pouvez lécher le sol
et si ça reste collé à votre langue,
c'est de la montmorillonite.
Ou alors, c'est que vous avez enlevé votre
combinaison, que votre tête a explosé
elle est allée rouler par terre
et est restée collée au sol.
Donc voilà les trois grandes raisons qui expliquent
pourquoi les géologues aiment lécher des cailloux,
en plus du grand plaisir de passer pour un con.
Ca peut aider à mieux voir de quoi est composée
une roche, voir si elle a un goût particulier,
ou aussi à estimer grossièrement sa porosité,
voir s'il colle à la langue ou pas.
Si vous aussi vous voulez tenter l'expérience
à la maison, faites attention,
c'est plus dangereux que ça en a l'air.
Ca dépend des spécimens qu'on prend,
mais certains peuvent être toxiques.
Ils peuvent contenir de l'arsenic, du cadmium,
du mercure, plein de choses merveilleuses.
Du plomb aussi, comme cette galène.
Tous les cailloux ne sont pas inoffensifs,
prenez de l'amiante par exemple.
C'est un minéral cancérigène.
Donc faites attention.
Si jamais vous testez ça chez vous, je vous
conseillerais de vous entourer d'un géologue
ou d'un minéralogiste, qui puisse vous dire
ça vous pouvez, ça vous pouvez pas.
Et tant qu'à faire, si vous voulez vous adonner
aux joies de lécher des cailloux,
autant le faire dans les règles de l'art.
Il y a deux techniques.
La première, c'est de lécher votre doigt,
de le passer sur l'échantillon
et de le lécher à nouveau.
Normalement, vous avez assez de goût pour
sentir le goût, sans ingérer trop de particules,
au cas où.
L'autre technique, c'est de laisser poser
le bout de votre langue pendant quelques secondes
sur le caillou.
Donc là, ça n'a aucun goût
puisque c'est un quartz.
Pour finir, désolée de briser vos fantasmes
mais les géologues ne passent pas leur temps
à lécher des cailloux.
Ça fait partie du processus d'identification
parfois, mais en général,
c'est au dernier niveau, donc on a déjà éliminé
toutes les autres solutions.
Mais bon, ça fait partie du folklore et
ça n'enlève rien à la magie de l'instant.
(musique)